We know neanderthals were a parallel group
of humans who went extinct tens of thousands
of years ago.
What if before it happened they asked for
our help?
Howdy humans, Trace here for DNews -- HOW
can you NOT find the story of neanderthals
riveting?
New research published in PLoS One examined
a 60,000 year-old neanderthal hyoid bone and
found our human cousins were likely able to
SPEAK!
The hyoid bone is situated right below the
jaw.
It's attached via muscles and ligaments to
the larynx, pharynx, epiglottis and the floor
of the mouth -- it's the ONLY bone in the
human body not attached to any other bone,
and it's main function is to anchor the tongue.
Around 300,000 years ago, a baby Homo heidelbergensis
was born with its hyoid bone slightly lower
than most.
It was attached to the larynx which allowed
this baby a lot more control of both its tongue
and layrnx, usually known as the 'voice box.'
Fish, amphibians, reptiles, mammals, birds
all have hyoid bones -- but only the homo
heidelbergensis had this strange dropping
mutation.
Both neanderthal and human descended from
heidelbergensis -- us in Africa and them in
Europe.
All this has been known for a while, but though
the neanderthal had a similar hyoid bone,
it wasn't until recently scientists could
show they had enough brains to make a language.
Researchers used new 3D x-ray imaging technology
to scan the 60,000 year old hyoid bone and
created a computer model.
The model revealed not only the external similarity
to modern humans, but also how the internal
structures were formed and shaped by the bone's
use.
The kicker?
The neanderthal bone is indistinguishable
from a modern human's, indicating it's highly
likely they used it the same way!
Neanderthals could speak!
This pushes language development in humanoids
even farther into the past.
It's been shown by paleontological and anthropological
studies before that neanderthals had art and
tools, they built houses and formed communities,
they even had religion and buried their dead,
but this is the strongest evidence yet this
was done with a verbal language.
When the homo-sapien arrived from Africa,
we could ALSO speak; though with a smaller
skull, and wider, shorter noses than the neanderthal,
our speech patterns were likely stronger and
more varied.
Evolving in warm, sunny Africa, the homo sapien
was better adapted for life on our planet,
with smaller eyes and a more evolved frontal-cortex.
The large eyes and bodies of the neanderthal
couldn't keep.
The homo sapien travelled in larger community
groups than the neanderthal, and either absorbed
or destroyed their population as they spread
across Europe and Asia.
Regardless of which, every year more evidence
comes out that these neanderthals weren't
mindless cavemen brutes, but were a parallel
culture of evolving beings.
Not only were we all talking sooner, but we
were perhaps a little more similar than we
once believed.
Which makes the history of these ancient people
all the more intriguing.
I wonder if ancient neanderthals and homo
sapiens talked to each other?
Were there translators?
We know we interbred, and lived at the same
time -- so... what do you think?
Share your musings below and make sure you
subscribe!
Thank you to everyone who gives us a like
and shares us with your friends.
You're all awesome.
Thanks for watching everybody.